The Lord of the Rings has many different types of people:
elf people, dwarf people, tree people, middle-class people, and even people.
There are about a million pages of backgrounds telling this world
That goes far beyond books and movies
but if you do not want to read them all,
here you have a stand of four minutes.
Let's start with the magicians.
It is easy to confuse magicians as trained humans in magic,
as in any other place.
But in the Lord of the Rings, the wizards are angels of a lower level.
They are called "Istari" (prepared for many names in this video)
and there are five: Saruman el blanco, Gandalf el gris,
Radagast the brown and the two blue magicians.
Its power basically comes from being supernatural beings, and not so much
of later learning.
They are sent to help people
of the world to deal with evil (for whom? we will see this more strongly)
Not totally successful.
Saruma, the leader of the five, with an iron mentality and "wheels"
It is corrupted, Radagast is distracted by the beautiful nature, the Blue Magicians
they fade to the east, possibly beginning magic sects,
and only Gandalf remains loyal to the cause.
Now, where there are angels, there is a God, and in this universe
is Eru Ilúvatar.
In the beginning, there was nothing except Eru, and the infinite and eternal nothing,
which is quite boring, so he created many angels to make him company.
The angels of Ilúvatar are called Ainur and are divided into two groups:
the Valar, guardians of the world, of whom there are fourteen
(or fifteen, depending on who you want to count)
and their lack, the Mayar.
The wizards are the Istari, a subgroup of the Mayar, who serve the
Valar, all creatures created by Ilúvatar.
Ilúvatar and all his angels sang together to create the world.
Harmony started well, but there was a Valar, called Melkor,
And just by name, Melkor, you know what will happen
before knowing that it is also the most intelligent and the most powerful
of the angels
And also a bit lonely.
Melkor did not want to be part of the choir, like his classmates Valar
less bright,
wanted his own song in creations.
And so his voice became disagreeing with that of others ...
and created all the suffering and evil in the world.
But Melkor's song also attracted some Maylar towards his band,
including the Balrogs, which means that Balrog is an angel of lower level,
putting it at the same level of power as Gandalf.
Which explains why an old man can fight a lava monster
giant
Through his disagreeable melody, Melkor also created some of the creatures
wicked people of the world, like dragons and trolls, what brings us
to think about things that are not angels.
Other Valar also created their own non-angelic creations, though
in a more cooperative spirit with Ilúvatar.
Manwë created the Giant Axes, Aulë created the dwarves,
and his wife, Yavanna created all the animals and plants of the world,
Before finishing it with the Ents, his
own race of conscious creatures.
While Ilúvatar seemed content to leave his Vala
To create the majority of things, he personally created
the men and the elves,
which makes them special, and in some way above all other creatures
you live
Sorry, dwarves
And, among these two, men are the favorite child of Ilúvatar.
And shows them by giving men a shorter life than the rest
and also the present of death?
Thank you very much, papa.
But his short life makes them separate from the other creatures, and no
They are linked to the music of creation and the world, something that others do.
So, they are able to forge their own futures.
This quality makes them the "We do things" of Middle-earth species.
The elves, on the other hand, are so much linked to the world as practically
They are made of nature. The same thing happens with the dwarves in their own way
and the Ents, of course.
These species basically follow the course of nature, and this is partly why
It's hard for humans to get them to do anything.
Even when faced with armies of orcs, what brings us to the orcs.
In Melkor he was powerful, but he could not make creatures as bright as elves and men,
so he cheated some of them at first and
raising them selectively over generations until they reach these creatures.
These issues were carried out by Melkor: torturing elves, creating monsters,
Recruit angels on the other side, eventually, but not surprisingly, they brought
to a war that Melkor loses and is banished into the void.
All the conflicts of the Lord of the Rings come long afterwards
of the epic battle between God and the evil of this universe.
Sauron, the great bad guy, who causes all the problems in the books,
It was only a Mayar, though an unusually powerful one
He began his career as a lieutenant in Melkor.
After the war he made a ring to concentrate all its strength, but that
It's a story for another day.
Last but not least, we have Hobbits.
Although they seem related to dwarves, since they live underground and
The vertical challenge, the Hobbits are a subspecies of men.
For being such an important race, there is little written about its origin,
Apart from the phrase "related to men".
Apparently, in a million pages still without being able to talk about everything,
like in a four-minute video.
♪
* Hello Internet # 13 background *